I'm Jim Moore and I'm going to show you
how to shine a pair of shoes in 90
seconds first thing you do is you take
your old can of shoe polish and get rid
of it you don't need it it's gonna weigh
you down you only need three things you
need a damp washcloth you need one of
these Express sponges and then you need
this liquid shoe polish now I'm doing a
pair of black shoes so I would do black
shoe sponge and black shoe polish
remember you've just come off the street
you probably walked on a dusty road so
your shoe is like in kind of bad shape
then you want to get some of that debris
off there so you're not polishing over
the dirt so I like to take the wet wash
cloth and just you know liberally clean
that shoe you have to do the bottom of
the shoe but you want to get the uppers
you want to get the sole and you
definitely want to get the heel then we
go right to the Express shoe sponge I
just love these things it's already got
the shoe polish in it so I just start
going at it because I'm already like
late for work so I've got to get this
thing polished and just go over twice do
the toe first do the sides the back you
can even go right onto the laces and
you'll see right away the shoe is really
coming up nice and high gloss now I'm
going to go to the liquid polish which
you only use for the sole in the heel so
you know give it a little bit shake
you're just going to run that along the
sole the back of the heel it's just
going to bring that soul and that heel
back to life what you have now is a
perfectly polished shoe hopefully we're
even under ninety seconds and you're
ready to go to a black-tie event to work
to the grocery store whatever
you missed a spot
do it right do it light do it wrong do
it long listen
measure twice cut once Jim I love you
come with me to John
you